my goal with the mentum II series is to
try to spend a little bit more time with
people who achieve more success in us
and hope that some of their magic dust
rubs off on to us so today we're going
to learn from Gary Vaynerchuk on
self-awareness point number five is my
personal favorite but I'm curious to
find out what you guys think
if you know who you are then by nature
you'll probably bet on your strengths if
you bet on your strengths you'll win in
fourth grade when I got an F and mr.
Mullen our science class I knew right
then and there that I was a student and
I wasn't and I didn't give a crap about
Saturn and no joke from that moment on I
mean I can taste it in my mouth right
now I remember everything about this day
I hid my I hid the test in my drawer
because I needed to get it signed this
was old-school eighties school stuff and
like I didn't show my mom and then my
conscience got the best of me and I
cried and it was all weird but what I
remember more than anything was at that
moment because I'd already done lemonade
and I already like sold random stuff
around the house door-to-door I was like
I'm a businessman
that's what I called it back then and
that's it and I'm never gonna hedge and
it came from self awareness and self
esteem right
my mom was making me feel good and I
knew who I was and I would tell you that
that is urgency you know speed matters I
believe an app but if somebody who's
listening watching right now if they
really know who they are like look
I want if my daughter wants to stand
outside and do street art for 19 hours a
day I'm all-in
as long as like she's aware that that's
what's going to make her the happiest
right like I got lucky that the thing
that made me the happiest by public
standards is something that makes me
money and makes me deemed successful
sure but boy I'd be super pumped being
all in on anything right like as long as
you just know
I wish that I could win on my looks but
I don't write like we have to know we're
gonna win on and too many people want to
be a pop singer or a comedian or a
pretty face model and it's just not who
they are and too many of you are leaving
enormous upside on the table by trying
to force a narrative that's romantic in
your mind versus what you actually have
yeah I could do so many more things to
build up my following but it's not who I
am I know the hacking ways to get more
followers to get more people to know who
I am but I'm a businessman that happens
to like understand content a little bit
so I'm never gonna be followed by the
most but I'm also that means not going
to sell things I don't believe in so if
you follow all the other entrepreneurs
on Instagram they're selling watches and
cash on bed and models and bottles and
private planes and I don't sell that too
because I don't want to get the cheap
followers or the cheap engagement yeah
and so when you really are self-aware
when you really know who you are what it
allows you to do is stay in your lanes
not do other things I can't produce the
kind of videos that my buddy Casey can I
can't like it's just not who I am and so
you've stained like my daily blog it's
just one exhausting episode of me
hustling 24 hours a day and honestly
eventually it's gonna be very repetitive
but I don't care that's my reality my
reality is I'm a workaholic who has some
talents but wants to show people that if
you work really hard if you want it then
at least you can get the most out of
yourself now not that you're gonna make
a billion if you work hard but the most
out of yourself so I think
self-awareness is imperative it's why I
put it in the new book
if you really want self-awareness you
need to wildly if you want to hack
self-awareness I actually think it's
predicated on on having thick skin I
think I think that is why I really think
so much of what I pull off is predicated
on how thick my skin is my skin is thick
you know I just can handle it I just can
I hate it I hate it I hate like reading
like you know bad stuff about me it's
just it's devastating but I respect it I
can accept it I understand it and I try
to use it as something that I go on the
offense with going forward and so
they're learning moments and so it you
know if you could get over yourself
right if you know and the funny thing is
like I don't know I feel like I'm so
self-aware I'm not sure I think but I
you know even like even people that I
think are not self-aware around me it's
funny to me how self-aware they really
are just you don't let your brain accept
your shortcomings
one thing I think I do well and at
vaynermedia is I make everybody feel
safe and so that's really important to
me because when you make people feel
safe they start telling you the truth
right so if you are able to go home
right now if you're struggling to figure
out what you're good at if you're able
to take the 10 to 20 people that are
closest to you
siblings wives husbands partners friends
the 10 to 20 people you consider the
closest to you in the world and if you
were able to talk to them and make them
feel safe
before you ask them the following
question if you made them emphatically
for 20 minutes and said look I need this
is the most important question I will
ever ask you in my life you need to tell
me the truth my intuition is you're not
going to want to tell me the truth but
you have to understand I'm okay with it
I'm in the right mind space for this I
need the truth and then you ask them
what do they think you're good at and
bad at it says it's an amazing and
obviously I put out that post it really
resonated I'm getting crazy emails of
people like having amazing things happen
to them I think the only if you do not
have self-awareness which is what I do
think I have and I think a lot of people
don't have it the only way you can gain
it is by getting other people to give
you the data points but most people
won't tell you the truth so it's on you
to create an environment a very safe
environment for somebody to tell you the
truth of what they truly think you're
good and bad at and then gather that
data a lot of people don't want to
recognize what they're good at or don't
want to accept that they're bad at
something it's like that whole American
Idol singing thing right like some of
people really believe they're great at
singing and they suck right like they
really believe it and so I don't think
people are honest with themselves
there's a lot of things I wish I was but
but I just don't lie to myself and I
think lying to yourself has held back
the far majority of this room from
bigger upside
I think everybody lies to themselves
being a dick about it I know I'm sitting
in a room full of number twos threes and
fours there's so many people in this
room that are like gonna be dot like
could be dominant number two threes and
fours and I'm pissed that the narrative
now is that you need to be a number one
and have your company because a lot of
people gonna lose or leave money on the
table because that's just the narrative
I really do think you have to audit who
you actually are you can look at like
how people roll and like it's great to
admire and things of that nature but
it's so damn important you need to bet
on your strengths and don't give a [ __ ]
about what you suck at way too many
people this room we're gonna spend the
next 30 40 years of their lives trying
to check the boxes other things that
they're not as good at and that you're
gonna waste a load of time and lose to
stick to like your DNA because the truth
is if you want to be an anomaly you've
got to act like one you know like and so
that's it that's what I got so thanks
for having me thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what you thought of the clips I'd
love to know which one was your personal
favorite leave it in the comments below
and I will join the discussion again I
appreciate you guys watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon I love to
give like definitive answers to get
people moving because the more you
ponder the more you squander